now once in a while we'll do a how to be
video centered around a superhero
however the funnest ones to do are about
super villains because more times than
not they're left living so that the
heroes have someone to fight in the
future all of batman's are still
breathing to this day because the cape
crusader refuses to kill and this is
something that is seen across the board
in comic books however the boys is
totally different there are several
characters that are actively trying to
kill homelander no matter what but they
just can't seem to do it so throughout
this video i'd put together all the ways
that i think the character can be
brutally murdered yay this also contains
which person i think has the greatest
chance against him and the abilities
that you better hope you get when you
shoot up some v24 now when gothennes was
first coming up with a concept for the
boys he made it clear from the earth
that he wanted the big weakness for the
soups to be their egos these are people
that can destroy the planet if they put
their mind to it but the idea of
celebrity twisted them into narcissists
that were desperate for attention just
the thought that someone might not like
them could send them off into an angry
rage and ultimately that's their biggest
weakness of all however it still doesn't
mean that they're easy to kill and with
the case of homelander there's several
gunning for him that all have their own
powers now the first is victoria newman
who will blow your head off down the
back alley after work like ryanair you
know what i'm not even gonna say it
anyway throughout the show there's been
this sort of will they won't they motif
with her and homeland over whether she
can actually kill him or not at the end
of episode 1 in season 3 we get a better
indication of her powers as she blows
someone's jaw first then part of their
head before destroying their entire body
can't show this on screen because of
youtube demonetization but just imagine
it's happening and imagine hitting that
bloody thumbs up button whilst you're at
it as well now to me this makes me think
that she can do more than just explode
someone's skull and she can control
blood on a molecular level to make it
exit the body at speeds strong enough to
rip it apart this is also hinted towards
when she taunts starlight after annie
refuses to side with her newman gives
her a nosebleed and says that it would
be difficult to kill her but not
impossible now i always took this
meaning that it would be difficult to
make it look natural rather than whether
vic could actually do it or not homeland
also taunted vic with trying to pop his
head when he went to visit her with v
for her daughter now because of this
control over blood i actually do believe
that she could kill homelander it would
just take a lot for her to do it this is
because when he was fighting against
maeve homelander ended up getting
stabbed in the air which caused him to
bleed now as they say in predator
if it bleeds
we can kill it and there's him having
blood makes me think victoria could kill
him if it came down to it it just
depends whether she could get the drop
on him first when he's spamming his eye
laser attacks now that takes us into our
next power which is likely another way
that he could be killed once and for all
now i don't think it's any coincidence
that both ryan and butcher both have
powers that center around being able to
shoot lasers out their eyes sure belize
comes from the compound whereas reins is
natural but still i feel there's a
writing reason about these characters
have this ability i think that's purely
down to the fact that it's a way that
can kill homelander and honestly i think
this will be what happens to the
character when he's taken out in his
final episode i mean it would be pretty
ironic if he went out this way
especially considering that he spams it
whenever he's in trouble this happened
on the airplane during the protest at
the end and even when he escaped the
battle at hirogasm so having him go out
like this would be bitter irony i think
that when the show is coming to a close
that it'll come down to ryan almost
killing his dad after he realizes how
bad he's become however butcher at this
point will then step forward take a
final shot of v24 unleash his own
eyelashes and kill a character once and
for all this would stop ryan from
becoming a murder rap and it would also
mean that billy's life goal is complete
i think this final shot will mean that
he succumbs to the compound but with him
living on borrow time already it'll be
him going out on his own terms now this
might not happen but i think that either
way the pair both have this power for a
writing reason plus we know from the
fighting hero chasm that the beams can
block each other so if homelander was to
use them then this is a way to stop his
favorite attack now we've also seen that
if used for long enough that the laser
beams are completely devastating
and though it's stormfront it was
initially used to don't be a [ __ ] laser
my [ __ ] tits come the end of season 2
she was completely ripped apart by it
now ryan having his exact same abilities
means that he can potentially stop him
if it comes down to it this is also
demonstrated in the source material in
them homelanders death came at the hands
of black noir who was revealed to be a
clone of him he had the exact same power
set but he'd hidden this from all the
other characters by just pretending to
be a ninja type of supes during 911 when
the seven were called in to stop a
hijacked plane he even ended up falling
from it to what should have been his
death if he was just a normal character
the legend told this whole story to huey
and even he recounted how no one knows
how black noise survived it but in
hindsight we know this was due to him
flying away this shows that if you have
the same skill set as homelander that
there is a way that you can take him
down i don't want to go over the whole
clonelander thing as that's been done at
death thousands of times in my videos
but black noir at least to me
demonstrates that ryan can kill him if
it comes down to it now there is another
way beyond this in the source material
before we jump into it though i just
want to let you know that we've created
eclipse channel that has a lot of heavy
highlights from our videos it's gonna be
the home of our shorts rather than
posting them out on this main channel we
haven't really got many subs at the
moment my dad's called me a
disappointment and i massively
appreciate everyone who decides to jump
over there and support that too who's
the real heroes you are now early on in
the comics the boys end up going to
russia in order to take down little nina
we discover that she got a refined
version of compound v that's capable of
exploding the heads of soups if the
correct radio frequency is used to
trigger it nina was planning a coup on
the country with board but the boys
ended up stubbing her before she and the
corporation were able to take control
little nina had an army of over 50 supes
and butcher arrived at the end of the
issue to destroy them all by blowing
their heads off using a detonator go to
the end of the comics and this is the
same method that butcher attempts to use
to wipe out every soup on earth he
climbed to the top of the empire state
building in order to carry this out and
he would have got away with it if it
wasn't for that meddling huey but this
shows that there is a way to kill soups
across the board and it would likely
also work with homelander who as we
discussed with victoria can be killed
using this method but how would he get
this specialized compound v into his
system after all it will be difficult to
get close to him and if bullets have
trouble breaking through his skin then a
needle probably would too sure you could
do what maeve didn't hit him in the weak
points like his eyes or his ears but i
can think of a much better way put this
special v in some bloody breast milk
[Music]
you made my day
[Music]
god damn i love some bitty from that
itty-bitty teddy what
now this would get the v into his system
so billy just go to vort fill up the
fridge and let the man's cravings do all
the savings now judging by the reveals
in season three we also know that
novichok can work as a way to subdue the
soups not only did this impair may when
they were in the process of transporting
her but we also saw how it kept soulja
boys sedated for several decades my
guess is that this nerve agent will
start popping up more and more down the
line and that it'll be used as one of
the main weapons by the boys to put him
to sleep worsen my voice in this video
lastly you could always just find a suit
that can shrink down and have him jump
into his
that would work and a hashtag justice
for termite so how do you beat homeland
out well either you just explode his
head shoot him with laser beams or use
black noir however i think we all know
that the best way to defeat him is to
just cancel him as i mentioned earlier
his ego is his biggest weakness and
though the guy threatened starlight with
destroying the earth if he was exposed i
think it's all a bluff she exposed him
throughout the series at numerous points
and even got him on camera admitting to
his crimes still he's showing up at
rallies being the head of vaught and
overall if he was gonna do it he would
have done it by now the guy's need for
love is too much and this of course
calls back to his childhood namely how
he was raised as a lab experiment so
what you need to do you just need to dig
up some old tweets post them on the
internet and act like you've never said
anything problematic or offensive in
your entire life because everyone is
self-righteous on the internet they'll
all join in two and do whatever they can
to be the real heroes before you know it
hashtag homelander is overparty will be
trending worldwide and he'll be reduced
to shivering and shaking like he's just
seen his dad pop up at a rally after he
told him capes are for
so go on you another celebrity taken out
until they inevitably return in a few
years time you're some of a [ __ ] i
still love you for it though anyway and
of course love to hear your thoughts on
how you take the villain out so make
sure you comment below and let me know
again please mate please subscribe to
our clips channel which will be linked
on the top comment otherwise i'm going
to be forced to do an oni fans now we
are also running a competition right now
and giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts and theories if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown on
how we think black noir will return
which will be linked on screen right now
we go over all the theories on it talk
about what eric kripke has said about
the character coming back so definitely
go check it out right after this by the
way thanks for sticking through the
video i've been paul i'll see you next
time take care peace